anybody can learn this concept here and
it's concept here is your contact
networking I can take my business back
to 1999 when I went to a man's house it
was a millionaire and he had a big party
and I made a lot of relationships after
the relationships 2003 that contact is
what led me to make him 30 million
dollars just off of one sale you know I
went to an insurance conference a few
years ago met a guy we didn't hit it off
we had a terrible call together one time
I'm talking a five minute call that was
horrible horrible call I said we'll
never do business with this guy he came
back saying I still want your business
what can we do to make this work we made
it work fast forward he's the one that
ended up putting me in contact with De
La Hoya and couple other guys that
raised ten million dollars for business
these were contacts we networked we went
through it you look at Zuckerberg he
goes to Harvard meets a kid named Edward
meets the Winklevoss brothers that leads
to Facebook you look at Warren Buffett
who networks and meets a guy named
Charlie Munger who he thinks is smarter
than he is and that bring those two
together build the empire that they
built everything's about networking in
your context especially if you want to
increase your wealth let me put it to
you this way it is very difficult for a
billionaire to befriend somebody that's
for twenty thousand dollars very
difficult you know why because the
experiences are different and level of
thinking is different if you hang with a
billionaire you're twenty thousand
dollars somehow someway is gonna get
higher somehow someway this thing gets
hard because you're borrowing their
thinking you're borrowing who they know
you're borrowing their associations